[Music]
people move a lot
but they go nowhere the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was the opposite he was always
moving forward
achieving the best results yet he did
not achieve
success on his own the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam developed the
sahaba to be able to share islam with
wisdom
in other words with sapience yes
that's exactly what the word means this
process culminated
in islam's rich intellectual and
spiritual heritage
this is why we at sapience institute are
dedicated in following this prophetic
method
by not just providing free academic
content but by proactively developing
intellectual activists and academic
leaders
your donations will help develop leaders
all around the world
create academic activists to
intellectually share islam
and educate others to do the same remove
doubts
spread by false ideas for generations to
come
in sha allah it's critical to continue
this important work together
be a leader be the first to donate
donate now
[Music]
you